Hallo. Hallo und herzlich Willkommen. Frohes Neues 2025 und auch zum Chaos Radio 297. Oh mein Gott, die 300 ist bald fort. Was machen wir da? Wahrscheinlich auch weiterhin digitale Dinge erklären, die für Interessierte, Ahnungslose und den Rest der Welt von Interesse sind oder sein sollten manchmal. Und dieses Mal machen wir was brandaktuelles, weil uns ist ja aus diversen Gründen hat uns ja eine Bundestagswahl ereilt. Und wie es die Tradition will, geht es da mal mehr und mal weniger auch um Digitalpolitik. Und ich will jetzt nicht sagen, dass wir die Digitalvalumat wären, aber vielleicht wisst ihr am Ende dieser Sendung ein bisschen besser, was die verschiedenen Parteien davon, was die verschiedenen Parteien versprechen, muss man tatsächlich sagen. Ob das dann auch so kommen wird, ist immer eine andere Sache. Aber vielleicht können wir auch das kurz beleuchten. Also das wollen wir heute eben machen. Mit dabei ist wie immer Konstanze Kurz, die mich jetzt schon wieder anguckt, als hätte ich ihren Bart gefressen. Hallo und guten Tag.
Hallo Markus.
Ja natürlich, es wird immer besser.
Wir müssen nur mal kurz sagen, nur falls jemand den Zynismus mit Christoph jetzt an der berkloppte Idee. Ja. Also nur mal kurz, um zu explizieren.
So, ähm, ich hab...
Ja, komm on.
Nein, ich bin kein, ich weiß ja, dass ich kein Freund davon bin. Es ist halt die, ähm, ich kann, also sagen wir's mal so, ich kann den grundsätzlichen Ansatz dahinter schon verstehen, wenn man sagt, wir machen Strafverfolgung, wir wissen, da gibt es Probleme. Aber ich hab Anbieter, die nicht kooperieren, also wo gar nichts passiert, wo ich weiß, da ist verschlüsselte Kommunikation in riesengroßen Gruppen mit, äh, was weiß ich, 100.000 Leuten. Und da wird CSAM, also Kinderpornografie drin geteilt oder irgendso was Ähnliches, das ist bekannt. Und ich komm da einfach nicht ran. Ich komme einfach nicht weiter. Selbst eine klassische Telekommunikation nützt mir nicht, so als alles verschlüsselte Kommunikation. Also ich kann den grundsätzlichen Ansatz, der dahinter steht, durchaus nachvollziehen. Die technische Probleme, die damit entstehen, die Unsicherheit der ganzen Geräte und ich krieg das ja nicht gesichert. Das ist völlig egal, wie ich versuche, diesen Zugang zu dieser Software, zu diesem Gerät dann zu sichern. Es sollen ja Strafverfolger da drauf und Strafverfolger sind ja nicht eins. Das sind im Zweifelsfall in Deutschland wären es Dutzende. Wir haben allein 160 Staatsanwaltschaften oder so was am Start. Und dann, es gibt ja auch noch andere Länder, wie will ich das regulieren? Da dürfen das jetzt die Deutschen, dürfen das die, was ich kann. In Europa kann ich das, in den USA kann ich das, aber in China raus aus Ländern, denen ich das nicht zutraue oder was. Es ist einfach nicht sicher, aber in dem Moment, wo mehr als eine Handvoll Keys draußen sind, wird das sowieso irgendwo missbraucht, ist nicht mehr kontroleriert. Man hat keine Zugangskontrolle mehr auf diese Sache. Das heißt, es ist im Prinzip alles offen. Es ist keine Nachschlüssel mehr für irgendwas. Es ist einfach offen. Und deswegen ist es natürlich prinzipiell abzulehnen. Völlig egal, wie kritisch, wie problematisch es dieser Phänomenbereich ist.
Man muss immer ganz am Anfang schon vorsichtig sein, weil es, egal was man da macht, das verhindert keinen Missbrauch an Kindern. Das verhindert vielleicht und nur vielleicht die Verteilung von Bildmaterial, das beim Missbrauch von Kindern entstanden ist.
Genau, ich finde das. Also ich würde auch ganz stark betonen wollen, dass es nicht nur ein Problem der IT-Sicherheit ist, sondern zum einen, dass es dann wirklich bei Kinderpornografie bliebe, dass dann die Strafbehörden darauf Zugriff bekommen. Also da muss man schon sehr gutwillig sein, um das zu glauben. Und der andere Punkt, Markus, den du jetzt angesprochen hast, ist das wirklich ein effektives, verhältnismäßiges Mittel, mit dem wir vernünftig gegen den Problem von Kindermissbrauch vorgehen. Genau, also ich meine dazu gibt es auch Studien. Deswegen, ich finde dieses Narrativ ganz, ganz schwierig zu sagen. Chatkontrolle, das ist da nicht nur vorgeschobenerweise um Kinderschutz.
Da habe ich zwei Antworten für dich. Wir betreiben ja auch eine Beschwerdestelle und haben als Eko ziemlich viel Tieflöte in diesem Bereich. Seit zehn Jahren, oder?
Länger noch.
Genau. Und also man unterschätzt, wie viel in diesem ganzen Bereich auch auf Anforderungen passiert. Live, Video-Streaming, sonst was, das gibt es da alles. Also es ist nicht nur, wenn du sagst, man schützt damit keine Kinder, das ist nicht richtig. Aber ich möchte gar nicht dem das Wort reden, weil du hast, der entscheidende Punkt hast du danach gesagt. Das ist einfach nicht verhältnismäßig. Und es ist völlig egal, man wird es damit nicht in den Griff kriegen und damit ist es auch schon unverhältnismäßig. Man gefährdet alle, man gefährdet die komplette IT-Sicherheit im weitesten Sinne, weil das ist dann die Bektor, die von Gott und der Welt verwendet werden kann.
Das war doch geschieht, das haben wir auch gerade erlebt. Das ist ja gerade der Vorteil, in den USA ist ja genau benutzt worden.
Kannst du kurz konkretisieren?
Der Schlagwort dafür ist Salt-Typhoon. Also das ist sozusagen die Nutzung durch Dritte. In diesem Fall wurden die Chinesen sozusagen als Angreifer, sind die Chinesen identifiziert worden, dass sie eben solche Überwachungsschnittstellen, Lofel-Interception-Schnittstellen ausgenutzt haben. Das heißt, wenn man Hintertüren baut, benutzen sie nicht nur die Guten.
Stimmt, da wurde ja nicht irgendwie auf.
Und so richtig alle, so Verizon, AT&T, sie haben neun große Anbieter mittlerweile. Also das ist einfach...
Da gibt es so eine klassische Telekommunikationsunternehmen, die dann aufgerufen haben, man soll Signal benutzen, weil alles andere sozusagen gerade umgesetzt ist.
Also der FBI hat gesagt, man soll entkryptet kommunikativ verwenden.
Okay, also das ist ein großes Thema. Ich halte mal fest, es gibt sozusagen so wenig Überraschung, die Spaltung, dass die Union denkt so voll gut, lass mal irgendwie alles überwachen. SPD eher so, lass mal alles überwachen. Grüne eher so, lass mal nicht überwachen, aber wir können nicht garantieren, dass wir da so viel machen können irgendwie.
Also dafür, dass wir das nicht lesen, das heißt, dass wir ganz gut zusammengehen.
Also ich möchte, nur weil wir in dem Bereich gerade sind, also das ist jetzt nicht direkt die Wahlprogramme, aber dieser ganze Bereich, der auch in der Politik ja überall wieder hochgespielt wird, der ist absolut verzerrt und der ist verzerrt durch NECMAC. Also das ist die amerikanische Meldestelle für NECMAC, also so nennt man es. Das ist NECMAC, also dort werden im Prinzip Funde bei amerikanischen Freunden, auch in Social Media und sonst was, irgendwas gemeldet und das wird dann weitergegeben bei uns an das BKA. Und dadurch kommen, ich glaub, letztes Jahr hatten wir um die 70.000, 80.000 Fälle.
Also Zehntausende.
Zehntausende, die da reinkommen, die werden dann versucht, weiterzufolgen. Das führt zu zwei Sachen. Aha, der Phänomenbereich ist overplayed, also wenn man nur die deutschen Fälle im Prinzip nehmen würde, wär es viel, viel weniger, ein weniger Bruchteil davon und wär auch wesentlich langsamer gewachsen. Und das zweite ist, da kommt dieser Vorratsdatenspeicherungsthing, weil die kommen dann mit Verzögerungen an und alles, was sie bekommen, ist eine IP-Adresse und seit November letzten Jahr auch noch eine IP-Adresse und ein Port. Und dann will man das auflösen und es sind keine Daten da. Also da kommt diese Vorratsdatenspeicherung-Diskussion wieder mit auf, weil man ja diese riesen Zahlen hat, die man nicht weiter verfolgen kann. Aber das ist nichts, was so diese klassische Weiterentwicklung von Kriminalität ist, wie wir es hatten, sondern es ist eine direkte Folge gewesen von diesen Meldeverpflichtungen, die man auch in den USA eingeführt hat, in Social Media, in Chatgruppen und so weiter und so fort, wo also die Anbieter das weitergeben müssen. Das ist so ein bisschen vergleichbar mit dem, was wir im Netz-DG hatten, mit Meldepflichten und solchen Geschichten. Also man muss deswegen auch immer ganz klar sagen, was passiert dann? Was passiert mit etwas, was konkrete Polizeiarbeit ist, wo etwas weitergegeben wird? Was kommt dann in der Politik an? Was wird verstanden? Wie sich eigentlich etwas entwickelt hat? Und zum Beispiel in diesem Bereich Vorratsdatenspeicherung sind wir dann ganz schnell bei dem Problem. Die Zahlen, die verwendet werden, sind einfach falsch, weil die wieviel kann aufgeklärt werden, kommt noch aus der Zeit als nur IP-Adressen ohne Ports gemeldet worden, seit November letzten Jahres hat sich das komplett umgedreht, weil die Ports mit reinkommen. Aber alle Statistiken in der Politik verwendet werden, sind noch die alten Statistiken mit niedriger Aufklärungsquote, obwohl die Aufklärungsquote mittlerweile sich ins absolute Gegenteil verkehrt hat. Also es sind nicht mehr 80 Prozent nicht aufzuklären, sondern es sind 90 Prozent aufklärbar, weil jetzt die Ports mitgeliefert werden. Was heißt das? Was heißt, wir fordern Vorratsdannenspeicherung ohne, dass wir es eigentlich müssten?
Genau, was genau, also Ports, das ist immer ein bisschen schwierig zu erklären. Also die IP-Adresse ist die Hausdauer des Internetanschlusses und der Port ist quasi die Öffnung im Haus, also die Vorder- oder Hintertür.
Ohne Port wäre ich hier nicht rein.
Entschuldigung. Aber davon gibt es dann halt irgendwie ein paar Tausend potentiell. Und am Port kann man sozusagen am ehesten erkennen, welcher Dienst es war oder warum erhöhnt das die Aufklärungsquote?
Nee, das Problem ist bei, das Problem entsteht durch Carriernet. Also wenn Network Address Translation nach außen verwendet wird, dann werden, dann wirst du ja übersetzt, du kriegst nicht aber nicht nur eine IP-Adresse Übersetzung, sondern es werden ja mehrere Nutzer sind dann auf einer IP-Adresse. Und wenn du den Port nicht mit lieferst, dann kannst du als Anbieter das nicht rückauflösen. Du kannst nicht sagen, es war der und der Kunde, weil es waren hunderte oder sogar tausende Kunden gleichzeitig, die diese IP-Adresse verwendet haben. Und deswegen war das so elementar und es hat jahrelang Arbeit, es war da auch beteiligt gekostet, dass das...
Der Port macht das sozusagen einfacher, die konkrete Verbindung nach so was.
Macht das überhaupt möglich, dass du als Anbieter sagen kannst, es war der Kunde.
Okay, jetzt sind wir sehr tief in das Thema.
Also das ist schon immer wichtig zu sagen. Also weil der, also okay, das ist natürlich ein komplexer Thema, aber ich finde Klaus hat den Punkt ja gemacht. Der Punkt ist, es ist unglaublich overblown und erfasst nicht, was eigentlich jetzt die technische Realität ist und zwar auch schon wieder seit Monaten, ja, sondern es ist eine überspitzte Definition, die auch immer nur bei der Überwachung ansetzt als Antwort und andere Bereiche total auslässt, was man ja auch tun könnte zum Beispiel präventiv. Und insofern, also, du kannst ja jetzt immer hinschauen als Partei, ja, Kinderschutz und so, ja, da sind alle dabei. Aber wenn du da mal intensiv drüber nachdenkst, auch doch die neuesten technischen Entwicklungen siehst, ja, dann stellt sich das in einem anderen Licht da. Aber nichts davon bildet sich in den politischen Diskussionen ab. Die Frage wird sein, ob sie letztlich, die entscheidende Frage wird sein, wie sich Deutschland nach der Wahl in der Chat-Kontrolle in Europa positioniert. Denn Deutschland, dadurch, dass sie bisher ablehnend war gegenüber diesen sozusagen Massenscannen, spielt eine wichtige Rolle für diese sogenannte Sperrminorität. Also werden es genügend Länder in Europa sein und Deutschland ist nunmal auch wichtig.
Dann jetzt nochmal, welche Parteien sind dagegen?
Äh, FDP und Linke. Also keine, die regierungsmäßig...
Also gegen Chat-Kontrolle sind die Grünen auch, also das ist klar. Aber die CDU ist dafür, muss man so sagen. SPD hab ich jetzt gerade nicht transparent, muss ich gucken. Wahrscheinlich wieder Splitt durch die Parteien, sie haben es deswegen nicht drinstehen. Deswegen hab ich im Moment keine klares...
Also wir haben gelernt, also viele interessante Dinge im Detail, aber wir haben vor allen Dingen gelernt, die Wahlprogramme für die nächsten Bundestagswahl sind nicht nur, wie noch nicht ganz fertig gemachte Hausaufgaben, sie sind auch veraltet.
Na gut, jetzt sind sie natürlich immer, das ist tatsächlich jetzt ja auch eine relativ neue Entwicklung. Okay, also...
Lass mir doch den einen Punkt. Lass mir doch den einen Punkt. Ich hab nämlich auch noch zwei Sachen sozusagen in diesen Themenfeldern. Das eine ist Plattformstrategien. Es gibt ja auf EU-Ebene mit dem Digital Services Act und dem Digital Markets Act mittlerweile Gesetzgebungen, die ist extra dafür gemacht, um mit einem neuen Problem umzugehen, also einem historisch gesehen neuen Problem, nämlich, dass es Digitalkonzerne gibt, die eine so große Macht haben, dass sie quasi supranational sind, also wie eigene Akteuren auf Staatsebene fast schon regieren. Das wird immer schlimmer, also gerade heute am Tag der Aufnahme hat Meta angekündigt, es würde jetzt nicht mehr mit Faktschekern zusammenarbeiten wollen und überhaupt dürfte man jetzt auch alles sagen ähnlich wie auf X. Das hat Mark Zuckerberg nicht gesagt, das ist meine Interpretation. Und es gibt aber eben in der EU diesen regulatorischen Einsatz. Man sagt, wir haben das Problem erkannt, es gibt diese riesigen Plattformen und weil die so riesig sind, sind die ein Problem und brauchen deswegen extra Regelungen. Bundestagswahl, 23. Februar 2025. Welche Partei verhält sich oder verhalten sich die Parteien dazu? Haben die sozusagen große Plattformen als Problem, das angegangen und immer in Betracht gehalten werden muss, erkannt? Oder ist es einfach ausgelassen?
Das geht nicht recht. Also das ist deshalb auch kein Schwerpunkt.
Also Sie sagen dazu oder ich finde, es gibt da eigentlich noch ein paar ganz interessante Nuancen. Also zum einen spricht die CDU zum Beispiel viel davon, dass Dinge souverän werden sollen. Also es ist dann immer so ein bisschen heißt, man soll eigene Cloud und Rechenkapazitäten aufbauen, um sich da zu lösen. Gleichzeitig sagen sie aber interessanterweise, also es gibt im deutschen Wettbewerbsrecht so ein Artikel, der auch ein bisschen anders ausgestaltet ist als dieser Digital Markets Act, der eben halt vor allem auf die Wettbewerbsthemen schaut. Da haben sie eine Formulierung drin, die sehr nahe legt, dass sie im Grunde genommen diesen Artikel abschaffen wollen und sagen, da die Entwicklung des Kartellrechts in Deutschland zurückdrehen wollen. Fand ich zumindest eine bemerkenswerte Inkonsistenz. Dann, ja und die anderen sagen halt vor allem, ja DMA, DSA, setzen wir durch. Die einzige Ausnahme hier, die mir aufgefallen ist, ist die Linke, die auch davon spricht, dort Zerschlagung durchsetzen zu wollen und eben halt überhaupt das Problem der Monopolisierung auf den digitalen Märkten viel präsenter diskutiert. Bei den anderen ist es eher dieses, ja wir finden das nicht gut, aber wir haben ja Gesetze, auch wenn die eben halt ja bisher wirklich noch keine nennenswerten Effekte entfalten haben.
Und das Einzelne ist vielleicht ein bisschen, also die Transparenzanforderung, das ist, was man jetzt schon sehen kann, gibt ja auch damit, gehen so einige Transparenz und Berichtspflichten einher. Da kann man jetzt mal reingucken, das ist mal interessant. Und sie haben so ein bisschen mehr Zugang zu Forschungsdaten, also wer jetzt damit forschen will, da ist auch schon was passiert, aber letztlich ist es relativ neu und es ist schon geltendes Recht. Insofern kann ich verstehen.
Aber die Aufsicht ist ja noch nicht richtig am Laufen, das kommt ja noch, das geht ja noch schnell.
Ich hab jetzt, weil ihr das jetzt schon ein paar Mal gesagt habt, als jemand, der sich für eine Wahlentscheidung treffen will, ist es mir zu wenig, wenn man sagt, das Thema ist geklärt. Also im Sinne von, da gibt es irgendwo, das ist mir zu wenig, sondern ich möchte, dass die Partei, die sich bei mir um meine Stimme bewirbt, ich möchte, dass sie sagt, folgenden, sozusagen folgenden Standpunkt haben wir da und bei EU-Gesetzgebung ist ja tatsächlich immer noch die Frage, also egal, ob das dann etwas ist, was noch im deutschen Recht umgesetzt werden muss oder ob das dann sofort gilt, aber eben auf die Einladung geguckt werden muss, da kann man sich ja auch zuverhalten, wie streng man das macht. Von daher kommt meine Frage und von daher ist mir das sozusagen nicht so ganz genug, wenn man sagt, gibt's ja schon.
Also es ist umgesetzt, um das erst mal zu sagen, digitale Dienstgesetz haben wir jetzt. Und es hat jetzt aber keiner gesagt, wir wollen das aufheben oder so was Ähnliches. Es steht in einigen Programmen explizit drin, dass das jetzt umgesetzt werden soll und dass man die, das will, was zu einem interessanten Spannungsfeld führt mit dem, was jetzt in den USA gerade passiert. Weil es ist jetzt in solchen Diensten extrem schwierig zu sagen, in den USA moderieren wir nicht und machen kein Fakchecking. Und was weiß ich, in Europa muss es jetzt gemacht werden oder so. Ich glaube als Europäer würden wir alle sagen, wir wollen, dass das passiert. Wir wollen auch von unseren Parteien, dass sie auf eine Umsetzung drängen oder dass man das eben, mir wäre es wichtig, also ich würde es gerne wissen, wenn eine Partei sagt, wir wollen es nicht mehr, das soll abgeschafft werden, aber es ist nicht so. Es wird unterschiedlich stark darauf betont, dass das umgesetzt wird und dass man eben jetzt hier da Maßnahmen machen soll. Aber wie gesagt, die Probleme, die sich ergeben, die werden wir jetzt erst dann dieses Jahr sehen. Und das wird nach einer Bundestagswahl sein. Das werden wir wahrscheinlich auch eher auf europäischer Ebene klären müssen. Und Alina hat ja eigentlich schon gesagt, die Einzigen, die sich wirklich noch, also inhaltlich signifikant unterscheiden werden, die Linken, die also sehr stärker auf diesem, genau.
Und also aber die, naja, die CDU oder die Union äußert sich an einigen Stellen schon eben auch explizit regulierungskritisch. Also nicht nur beim Thema Datenschutz, sondern fordert auch nochmal mehr Freiräume für KI und so. Also da kann man natürlich sagen, ja, das ist eigentlich alles schon beschlossen. Aber da gibt es auch irgendwie so einen Unterton von Nein, nein, wir wollen da nichts über erfüllen. Wir setzen wirklich nur das um, wo wir nicht anders können.
Und das haben sie auch explizit geschrieben, ne?
Genau, genau. Also das ist halt zum Beispiel bei den Grünen ein bisschen anders auch nochmal. Also die sagen schon auch noch, dass es, ähm, was war die, dass sie die großen Digitalkonzerne überhaupt mal problematisch finden. Und da Regulierung halt sinnvoll finden. Das ist bei der Union ein komplett anderes Narrativ. Das finde ich schon noch wichtig.
Da muss man noch einen nicht erwähnten europäischen Regeln hinzunehmen. Das passt nämlich hier dazu, nämlich der AI Act, also die KI-Verordnung. Die ist ja jetzt auch geltendes Recht und offenbar, also da sind ja auch noch ein paar Sachen unklar, wie sie umgesetzt werden. Auch von der Aufsicht und so. Da ist offenbar bei der CDU der einzig große Unterschied, die einfach sagen, so wenig wie möglich. Also das wird dann nur so in diese Hemd-Innovation geschoben.
Das ist bei der FDP nicht, das überrascht mich gerade ein bisschen. Weil hätte ich auch gedacht, dass die eher regulierungsfeindlich sind.
Eine kritische Regulierung von AI, also von KI-Systemen. Das ist generell halt eine Sache, man muss so ein bisschen diese Frage stellen, wenn ich sage, ich möchte nicht über das hinweggehen, was in Europa passiert ist, wie die CDU das macht. Oder wenn ich sage, ich brauche eine bessere Umsetzung, ich brauche eine maßvolle Regulierung hier, meine ich damit eigentlich was anderes. Also ich meine, das ist vielleicht nur ein unterschiedliches Wording, aber im Endeffekt kommt genau das Gleiche bei raus. Und da muss ich auch ganz klar sagen, da werden wir eh nicht viel Gestaltungsspielraum haben. Also man kann da zwar in einigen Punkten theoretisch drüber hinausgehen. Das will man, wenn man die Wirtschaft fördern will, wird man das nicht machen. Und man sieht ja überall, quer durchs ganze Wahlprogramm, AI eins als hier, AI eins als dort, in der Verwaltung dort und so weiter und so fort. Da würde man sich ja selbst im Prinzip ein Bein stellen, wenn man dann deutlich über das hinausgehende, was von der EU kommt, Regulierung fordern wird oder selber aufbauen wollte. Ich erwarte da gar nichts, was von keiner der Parteien irgendwas was über, das was von der EU als Mindestvorgabe da ist, hinweggehen wird.
Aber das wäre jetzt ein bisschen mit der KI ein bisschen mein letzter Punkt gewesen. Aber das sieht also durch die Bank weg, die Parteien als eher Chance, als Risiko?
Würde ich so sehen. Aber mir ist, also ich würde gerne nochmal einmal auf die Metaebene wechseln. Mir ist aufgefallen, weil wir jetzt so viele europäische Regelungen hatten, die Digital Market, das Act und KI-Verordnung und so. Die Schwerpunkte, wie stark man sich irgendwie auf Deutschland fokussiert oder wie stark man Europa oder sogar Internationalität mit reibt, finde ich krass unterschiedlich. Am stärksten ist es mir auf jeden Fall bei den Grünen. Die schreiben sehr viel über Europa. Auch mit so ein paar Begriffen, wo mir überhaupt nicht klar ist, was die damit meinen. Also ich nehme immer ein Beispiel, so was wie sie wollen den europäischen Binnenmarkt vertiefen und eine vertiefte Digital Union und so. Also sie haben auch manchmal Sachen, die ich dann gar nicht, ich weiß gar nicht, was sie damit meinen. Aber der Fokus ist teilweise krass unterschiedlich. Von ich blicke letztlich auf mein Land zu einem umfangreichen europäischen Blick. Also wer sich zum Beispiel jetzt so sagt, okay für mich spielt nicht nur eine Rolle, ja, irgendwie digitale Fragen im nationalen Raum, sondern auch im europäischen und sogar internationalen Raum, der wird am ehesten, finde ich, bei den Grünen. Fand ich bemerkenswert unterschiedlich.
Wobei das ja eigentlich, also total realistisch erst mal ist, dass viele dieser Themen ja einfach auf EU-Ebene behandelt werden, was ja gerade, also wir sind ja gerade noch eigentlich darüber reingekommen, auch über diese Frage nach den großen Digitalkonzernen.
Genau. Also das ja auch... Geht ja gar nicht anders....
sinnvoll ist, dass auf deutscher Ebene, also man kann halt immer was anstoßen, aber da wirklich mehr erreichen wird man auf EU-Ebene. Aber da ist Deutschland eben nun mal auch eine wichtige Stimme. Also deswegen finde ich, ist es total sinnvoll das von vornherein so zusammen zu denken und ja, also da...
Mir ist nur einfach auf jeden Fall.
Aber ich... Sorry, wenn ich das da ganz kurz nochmal, bevor wir zu KI gehen, das nochmal ganz kurz kommentiere, weil ich nämlich schon finde, dass man bei Digitalregulierung prinzipiell mehr machen könnte.
Ach so, diese Auslassung, ja, ja.
Also da ist einfach sozusagen, ja, wir haben jetzt ja den DSA, also und gleichzeitig passieren gerade Dinge mit Maske und so weiter, auf die irgendwie keiner so richtig vorbereitet war, bei denen halt irgendwie viele sagen so, hm, ja, also legal ist das, aber eigentlich ganz fürchterlich. Also wie gehen wir damit um? Also ich glaube, da überhaupt nochmal, sich die Risiken von Digitalisierung vor Augen zu finden, beziehungsweise inwiefern das gestaltet werden sollte, das ist, ja, da würde ich also sagen, eindeutig bei der Linken der Fall, aber halt auch in Ansätzen bei den Grünen, aber bei den anderen halt komplett, ja, Digitalisierung ist doch vor allem gut.
Bei der Fairness, wir haben ja die derben, die sind so um 17, 18, 12, wenn man so richtig losging mit, also vor allem, wenn man so sieht, dass die großen Tech-Konzern in den USA sehr stark kompisieren, also die bretten sich offenbar auf, die macht immer noch vom Trump davor, ist es tatsächlich erst so nachher richtig in der Debatte, das heißt, so schriftlich abbilden konnten sie noch nicht, Aber ich zeig dir, es hat ein bisschen wenig so, ja. Alle gammeln über Desinformation und Beeinflussung des Netzwerkes und dann hatten wir ja noch diese Urteil zu Rumänien, die wollen und so. Und das trifft nicht wirklich. Also das war eigentlich schon vorher klar, bevor jetzt irgendwie die Masken-Sackerung und Visos und jetzt auch Tim Cook irgendwie auf Trump.
Millionen spenden und zu Kreuze kriechen, das ist echt schlimm.
Also so ein bisschen, ich teile das aber, ich würde sagen im Wahlkampf wird es wieder keine große Rolle spielen, außer wenn es vielleicht so weiter geht und Musk jetzt irgendwie jede drei Tage irgendwann zur AfD und zu Olaf Scholz sagt, dann vielleicht. Ich weiß nicht, ob es so weitergehen wird. Keine Ahnung. Also ja, wenn der Mittel kriegt, irgendwie Olaf Scholz sagt jetzt irgendwie Don't feed the troll, womit er sich ja explizit zu Musk äußert. Also damit geht der wieder los, medial. Ich bin gespannt, wie das wird. Sind ja nur noch sechs Wochen. Die halten wir noch aus.
Mal sehen, es hatte ich am Anfang angekündigt, dass wir jetzt jetzt noch mal jeder Partei einzeln widmen und ich frage mich, ob das notwendig ist. Ich kann vielleicht noch mal ganz kurz abfragen. Aber auch die Antworten auf die Fragen, die ich jetzt stelle, klang schon so ein bisschen durch. Trotzdem noch mal, wenn also welche, welche Parteien haben ein digitales, einen digitalen Teil in ihrem Wahlprogramm, den ihr wirklich als digitales Wahlprogramm bezeichnet würde? Und wer hat eher so die Augen, nein, das müssen wir auch noch irgendwo abschreiben, die Hausaufgaben. Gibt es irgendjemanden, der sich vortut, wo ihr sagt, ja, das ist doch mal ein ordentliches Programm, auch wenn man jetzt vielleicht nicht irgendwie nicht übereinstimmt, bin halt nicht aber sozusagen im Sinne von, da hat sich jemand wirklich Gedanken gemacht. Und ich meine jetzt nicht die Länge, weil es ist sehr einfach, sehr viel Text zu produzieren, sondern wo sagt ihr, diese Partei hat tatsächlich ein Wahlprogramm beschrieben, aus dem ich lese, dass sie sich mit dem Thema auseinandergesetzt haben. Und nochmal, ich meine damit nicht, dass sie inhaltlich damit übereinstimmt, sondern einfach sozusagen, die haben, wenn es ein Debatierclub wäre, ihre Hausaufgaben gut gemacht.
Ich hatte vorhin ganz eingangs schon mal erwähnt, dass das digital überall so reingesickert ist mittlerweile. Und das zieht sich durch alles durch, egal über was die reden, ob die über Zusammenhalt in der Gesellschaft, über digitale Antragstellungen, über alles Mögliche. Digital ist einfach überall da drin, aber nicht mehr so explizit als eigenes digitales Wahlbuch. Und das hab ich eigentlich bei der FDP, glaub ich, so ziemlich als einziges, als echten Zusammenhängen, ein Block von den Forderungen, aber auch nicht wirklich das Neue. Das sind eigentlich die ganzen alten Forderungen, die sie da drin hatten. Die haben das so kondensiert, noch mal da zusammengezogen. Bei den anderen ist wirklich Digitalisierung mehr so ein Given durch alles durch jetzt. Irgendwie ist es mein, also mein Taste zumindest da drauf.
Ich bin da ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so entschieden, ob ich das so problematisch finde, weil das aus meiner Sicht schon noch ein Stück weit hier abbildet, dass Digitalisierung, wenn man das davon so sprechen kann, halt etwas ist, was Dynamiken in allen möglichen Gesellschaftsbereichen nach sich zieht und also deswegen, ja, das kommt ja auch überall, das ist ja so. Dass man sowas wie IT, dass es bestimmte Themen gibt, bei denen wir uns mehr Prominenz wünschen, liegt glaube ich auch daran, dass wir da halt so tief drinstecken, aber wenn man sich fragt, wie berührt das Menschen auf der Straße, wie man so schon sagt, also was für ein Unterschied macht das in dem Leben von Menschen, dann ist es doch auch eher ein Querschnittsthema und da finde ich es vielleicht nochmal diese Frage nach Verwaltungs-Digitalisierung digitaler Staat, da hab ich so den Eindruck, da wird unterschiedlich viel drüber geredet.
Ja, aber dann haben wir eine fiese Auslassung jetzt wieder, also thematisch und wenn du jetzt sagst, ok, was den Alltag von Menschen irgendwie betrifft, dann müssen wir glaube ich zumindest nochmal kurz ansprechen, was sagen die eigentlich zu Digitalisierung in der Bildung und in den Schulen und so. Da sind ein paar Unterschiede und das glaube ich, das wird viele Menschen im Alltag ziemlich für Kinder und Enkel und so interessiert. Also da finde ich, da wird es oft konkreter. Ich will mal ein Beispiel nennen, weil mir das so aufgefallen ist. Also natürlich die Parteien, die jetzt regiert haben, die betonen natürlich so ein bisschen, gerade im Bereich der Digitalisierung der Bildung, dass sie schon einige geschafft haben. Das ist mir generell so aufgefallen. Die Ampelparteien haben natürlich jetzt in ihren Zukunftsprogrammen auch immer noch mal drinstehen, was sie alles schon toll und geschafft haben. Na gut, aber so wie sie sagt, wir wollen klar machen, dass das für uns ein Thema ist, dass die Schulen digitalisiert gehören und dass wir Leute unterstützen wollen, die vielleicht nicht so viel Kohle haben. Das haben halt einige explizit drin. Und das ist mir persönlich zum Beispiel, glaube ich, für viele Leute im Alltag wichtig. Also die Grünen haben zum Beispiel explizit drin. Sie wollen so ein Zukunftsinvestitionsprogramm Bildung, das nennt sich auch so. Sie wollen mit den Ländern mehr arbeiten. In der Bildungspolitik, das ist ja viel Länderarbeit und so weiter. Die Linken haben es drin. Also die SPD erwähnt. Also ich finde nur den Bereich und so richtig so digital ausgestattete Klassenräume, also da haben sie mehr, da wird es ein bisschen konkreter, jetzt auch nicht übermäßig und wir wissen ja auch, dass der Bund nicht so viel regeln darf, es ist ja schließlich eine Bundestagswahl.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, es wohlfeil, da Dinge zu versprechen.
Ja, aber zumindest, also so Schwerpunktmäßig würde ich jetzt schon so sehen, während ich mal ein Beispiel nenne, womit bei die Schuhe ausgezogen hat, auch weil ich offen gestanden vom BSW noch nie ein Wahlprogramm gelesen habe, die haben auch noch eine relativ kurze, das ist eine Stichwort-Sammlung. Da geht es ja im Wesentlichen um Sozialität, um Migrationspolitik und um Ukraine, andere Themen haben die ja kaum, aber sie haben einen Absatz drin, völlig aus der Kalten. Ich lese mal kurz her, ich lese euch das mal kurz vor. Sie wollen ein Social-Media-Gesetz nach australischem Vorbild. Genau. Und das ist ja, weil die das mitbekommen hat, die wollen ja fürs, oder der Plan in Australien ist ja, für soziale Medien ein Verbot für alle unter 16 Jahren. Wobei das natürlich, also nicht Messenger und auch nicht YouTube, sondern nur große Plattformen wie TikTok oder Instagram oder Twitter.
Die beziehen sich drauf, naja auch Twitter sozusagen, fällt da vielleicht nicht zwangsweise auf.
Doch, Twitter fällt drunter.
Pass auf, sie beziehen sich drauf, dass die Social Media Plattformen gesperrt werden sollen, die nicht öffentlich wahrnehmbar sind. Das heißt alles was Twitter machen würde ist, sie würden wieder ausschalten, dass man einen Account braucht, um die Sachen zu lesen, dann würden sie schon wieder nicht über diese Regelungen fallen. Und Fun Fact in der Sideline, das wird mit Kinderschutz verargumentiert. Was tatsächlich politisch in Australien passiert ist, ist, dass sie eine Auseinandersetzung hatte mit dem Murdoch-Imperium. Und das Murdoch-Imperium hat daraufhin eine Kinderschutzkampagne installiert, die sagt, wir müssen doch schützen. Und das Ziel ist sozusagen, den Plattformen Reichweite zu nehmen, weil man denkt, dann kommen die Leute wieder auf die klassischen Medienseiten. Also als politische Partei in Deutschland zu schreiben, wir wollen was nach dem Vorbild von dem, was in Australien passiert ist, das ist für mich schon fast so ein Single-Point-Offen unwählbar.
Also ich war auch überrascht, weil das der einzige ist, wo Sie mal so Bildungs- oder Kinder- oder Jugendlichen-Themen erwähnen. Also Sie haben noch einen Satz danach. Sie verbinden das mit der Förderung von Sportvereinen, die sollen lieber rausgehen. Und ja, ja, ja, warte, und dann haben Sie den Satz, statt krank machender Social Media-Algorithmen brauchen Kinder mehr Bewegung, Spaß und Freunde. Auch außerhalb der Schule. Also die haben, also sonst kommt nichts in diesem Kurzprogramm dazu. Und das haben Sie dann drin. Ich dachte so, what?
Und das ist total fantastisch, weil das Social Media-Algorithmen sozusagen nicht gut für uns und die Gesellschaft sind. Da kann man total trefflich drüber sprechen.
Ja, aber wir verbieten es nicht.
Aber das damit zu verknüpfen, das war, naja, okay.
Und dann steht aber auch nicht wirklich drin, also wenn du das liest als unbedarfter Leser und gar nicht weißt, weil die in Australien da gerade debattieren, wir müssen es ja eigentlich ein bisschen explizieren. Also ich musste die Passage zweimal lesen, für mich ist damit das BSW auch nicht mehr wählbar, falls man das vorher überhaupt erwogen haben könnte.
Aber auch da, Konzernz, das klang jetzt bei dir so ein bisschen als Sein, da viele ähnlich positioniert. Also vielleicht ist das innerhalb der Ampel, aber darüber hinaus ist das Spektrum schon groß. Stimmt. Bei der CDU hat man halt beispielsweise die Schüler-ID, wohingegen die Linke dann so einen Satz hat wie KI darf nicht für Bewertung oder die Vorhersage von Lernerfolgen eingesetzt werden. Das sind glaube ich schon unterschiedliche Visionen, die dahinterstehen.
Ja, richtig, das sollte man betonen. Ich habe jetzt ein bisschen auf die Ampel oder die Ex-Ampel abgestaltet, stimmt ja.
So, noch mal zum Schluss sozusagen kleiner Rundgang durch die Parteien. Also oder müssen wir noch einen Parteienrundgang machen oder haben wir eigentlich alles?
Ich würde eine Sache noch erwähnen, die mir auf jeden Fall ist, die niemand anders hatte, was digitalen betrifft. Darf ich?
Na bitte?
Na, mir ist auf jeden Fall im grünen Programm steht explizit, dass die Barrierefreiheit konsequent umgesetzt werden soll, dass sie öffentlich zugängliche Angebote und Dienstleistungen sozusagen hinsichtlich der Barrierefreiheit stärken wollen und allerdings auch eine Überforderungsklausel für kleine Unternehmen haben und ein digitales Barrierefreiheitstool anbieten wollen zur Unterstützung. Das fand ich sehr konkret, war auch so ein bisschen wenig eingebettet, aber das ist eine sehr konkrete Forderung, die ja letztlich auch nur umsetzt, was ja eigentlich schon in den Gesetzen steht und aber eine Hilfe ist. Also mit einem, weiß nicht, ist mir jetzt aufgefallen, ist euch das aufgefallen?
Mir ist es aufgefallen, aber das fiel bei mir unter die Kategorie wieder so ein Ding, was schon gesetzt ist. Also wo wir einfach nur in der Übergangsfrist sind, nein ist, weil wir in der Übergangsfrist sind. Wenn das nicht zurückgerollt wird, muss es umgesetzt werden, muss jede Webseite diese Einbindung haben und so weiter und so fort.
Aber wir haben auch Apps und so, eine Dienstleistung haben wir.
Ja, aber die Integration musst du ja sowieso leisten. Also als Unternehmen musst du die Integration leisten, dass eben der Hilfsdienst desjenigen, der das in Anspruch nehmen muss, eingebunden wird bei dir, unabhängig davon, was dieser Dienst ist. Meistens so super komplizierte Geschichte momentan, aber das kann man vielleicht noch verbessern und kann das anders machen. Ich finde es schön, dass Sie es erwähnen.
Sie erwähnt halt, na ja genau.
Ich finde es schön, dass Sie es erwähnen, aber für mich sind immer diese Erwähnungen von etwas, was schon umgesetzt ist eigentlich oder was sich in der Umsetzung befindet, ist immer extrem schwierig. Also diese Sachen, die eh schon verpflichten.
Ja, okay, da ist ein Punkt, ich bin ja so unentschieden, weil einerseits gibt es gerade in der politischen Kommunikation immer die Gefahr zu sagen, guckt mal her, was wir tolles fordern, aber es gibt es eigentlich schon. Und andererseits finde ich es aber auch, was ich vorhin gesagt habe, finde ich es auch sozusagen nicht unwichtig zu sagen, also es gibt hier diese Dinge, die gibt es schon und zu denen bekennen wir uns auch. Ich bin da aber unentschieden wie Romans, also ich muss gerade an dieses Beispiel aktuell denken, es gibt gerade Banken, die sagen so liebe Kunden zu eurem Vorteil, was wir jetzt machen ist Echtzeitüberweisung, kostenlos, das machen wir für euch. Das ist gesetzlich vorgeschrieben, dass das jetzt so sein muss. Und das gibt es natürlich beim Wahlversprechen genauso, deswegen bin ich so ganz unsicher. Aber ich fände zumindest sozusagen einen erwähnenswerten Unterschied, ob das Thema Barrierefreiheit in einem Wahlprogramm überhaupt vorkommt oder nicht, das fand ich jetzt schon.
Aber das grüne Wahlprogramm tut generell sehr viele Sachen, die jetzt umgesetzt wurden oder die sie quasi erreicht haben auch und so weiter. Eine Fortschreibung davon, eine Weiterführung davon, das aber auch noch mal zu erwähnen im Prinzip. Das ist generell auch mit der europäischen Einbettung, die wir vorhin schon angesprochen haben, aber das ist eigentlich so das generelle. Ja, die CDU ist eher so bei dem, was wollen sie anders machen, was wollen sie wieder abschaffen, damit auch ein Vieles davon eigentlich gar keine Abschaffung ist, wenn man es mal genau nimmt, weil es gar keine Konzepte dafür gibt. Man schreibt einfach nur, wir wollen das wieder abschaffen, irgendwo zwischendrin, weil das sind immer so die Highlights, die man nicht mag bei dem anderen, aber eigentlich, wenn man alles außen rumliest, wollen wir genau das gleich in der Dock wieder umsetzen. Das fand ich sehr, sehr schwierig in dieser ganzen Geschichte. Was auch, wenn wir jetzt super allgemein sind von den Parteien, ist mir auch aufgefallen, es ist natürlich jetzt aus der Wirtschaft sehr unternehmerfreundlich. Also da ist so eine typische März-Handschrift irgendwo drin. Also ich will mal von dem Hintergrund her sagen, weil viel ist dann auch gute Ideen, muss ich als Unternehmer, ich bin ja selber auch Unternehmer, muss ich immer sagen. Also es sind viele gute, es sind viele gute Näher, also Sachen, wo wir echt Lücken haben, was ich, das ist Start-up-Förderung, Wagniskapital-Themen und so weiter, die wir nehmen, also die haben wirklich viele gute Sachen da drin, die in Deutschland nie funktioniert haben und die jetzt auch erst mal nicht gegen die, die ich jetzt auch nicht negativ empfinden würde, auch soziale sowas nicht als negativ empfinden würde. Schön, dass es mal einer aufgeschrieben hat und zum Wahlprogramm gemacht hat. Das ist tatsächlich einer der, ein positiver Aspekt da drin. Also das muss man glaube ich auch mal erwähnen. Ansonsten ist es halt generell so, wer hat sich auf soziale Themen mehr bezogen? Das ist halt ganz klar auch mehr so bei SPD und so was, das ist ja nicht überraschend, ja. Aber das Grüne Wahlprogramm ist auch sehr stark unternehmensorientiert oder überhaupt wirtschaftsorientiert. Also Wirtschaft ist ganz klar bei CDU, CSU und bei den Grünen das zentrale Thema. Das, naja, also...
Und Digitales wird dann eben halt oft für diese Zwecke wiederum genutzt. Also wir sind jetzt ja ein bisschen über das Thema KI geskippt. Und da fand ich, hat sich das auch noch mal ganz interessant so aufgezeigt, dass die CDU, oder die Union mal wieder, also halt sagt, sie hätte gerne KI und Cloud für die Zitat Reindustrialisierung. Und gegen mir dann auf der anderen Seite vom Spektrum halt die Linke haben, die sagen, es geht darum, Technologien zu bewerten im Hinblick auf ihren Nutzen für die Gesellschaft. Interessant, dass man sowas halt sagen muss und damit dann auch plötzlich so alleine steht. Und da fand ich zum Beispiel bei der SPD ist teilweise so ein bisschen erschreckend, dass sie schon auch viel so setzen auf so etwas wie KI als allgemeines Heilsversprechen. So, wir wissen nicht so richtig, wie wir das angehen. Also werfen wir KI drauf, so als, ja. Oder auch Quantentechnologie kommt da ein paar Mal drin vor, wo man ist so ein, okay. Ja, also da finde ich, ist so ein kritisch oder aufgeklärter Umgang mit digitalen Technologien, lässt an vielen Stellen noch zu wünschen übrig. So dass, also ja, ich da auch mal wieder ein bisschen hin und her gerissen bin, so hätte ich mir gewünscht, dass sie da mehr zu schreiben. Naja, also wenn sie sich halt, genau, wenn sie sich mehr dazu informiert hätten, super. Aber auf dieser Ebene, auf der das da aktuell passiert, denke ich, wird dann, gestaltet es lieber hinterher vernünftig aus, wenn ihr entschieden habt, was ihr wollt, statt da irgendwie so steile Thesen in den Raum zu stellen, die halt sehr schwer zu halten sind. Ah, ein Punkt noch, sorry, mein absoluter...
Bizarometer?
Ja, wow. Die FDP bringt das Thema Bitcoin wieder ganz nach oben und möchte Krypto ETFs. Also genau und fordert Bitcoin als, wie war das, als anerkannte Währungsreserve bei der Europäischen Zentralbank. Wow.
Ja, dann könnte die vielleicht die Europäische Zentralbank wieder ein paar Atomkraftwerke aufmachen, um zu meinen, ne?
Soll die Fett doch jetzt auch machen im Nachtraum. Aber mein, weil du es eben gesagt hast, also das ist übrigens auch ein generelles Signal, also ich meine, hier wird überall KI geschrieben, aber irgendwie ein klares Energiekonzept, wie man die mit Energie versorgen könnte oder wie man überhaupt das hinkriegt, das ist auch so ein bisschen, es kommt zwar vor überall so ein bisschen, alle wollen sie energiegünstiger machen, aber so richtig klar, wie machen wir das jetzt eigentlich oder wie wollen wir das eigentlich angehen. Da fehlt mir so ein bisschen die Vision, wie das weitergehen soll, dass wir das so weiter beeinigen und oh, wir prüfen mal wieder mal, ob wir nicht doch noch Nukleare wieder machen können bei der CDU oder so, aber immerhin ist es nur noch ein, wir prüfen mal.
Ja, alle Energieversorger haben ja gesagt nein.
Genau, das passiert sowieso nicht, das ist viel zu teuer, also ganz realistisch, auch pro Kilowattstunde und sonst einfach viel zu teuer, wenn man sich die Preise von denen, was jetzt in Frankreich online gekommen ist oder was da in den UK gebaut wird oder sonst, wenn ich das runterbreche auf Preis pro Kilowattstunde ist das einfach utopisch. Aber für diese ganzen KI's, die überall stehen, da muss man ja erst mal Rechenleistung, Data Center und so weiter bereitstellen und irgendwie muss ich die mit Strom versorgen und das wird noch mal eine spannende Aufgabe. Und da fehlt jegliche Antwort drauf, also wir schreiben überall KI rein, so Passworts, Internet, aber dass man das eben mit einem tragfähigen Versorgungskonzept versehen muss, weil es halt eine Konkurrenz ist. Da wird in den USA offener darüber gesprochen, dass das eine Konkurrenz ist. Das haben wir hier jetzt in unserem Wahlkampf zumindest nicht reingeguckt.
Ja, das stimmt auch bei Bitcoin nicht. Also bei Alina hat ihr jetzt auch kurz die FDP-Forderung für Pizaromete erwähnt. Das ist alter, denkst du auch echt.
Ich würde gerne, also so am Ende dieser Sendung stellt sich für mich wenig überraschend vielleicht, aber man kann ja immer mal wieder versuchen heraus Wahlprogramme sind vor allen Dingen, da ist Wahlprogramme. Also sagen für eine beliebige Definition von belastbar sind sie belastbar, aber ich weiß nicht so genau, wo die liegt und würde dann eine Abschlusszuspitzungsrunde mit euch machen wollen und zwar für die nächste Legislaturperiode könnt ihr euch ein für euch wichtiges digitales Thema aussuchen und sagt mir dann, welche Partei oder vielleicht sogar Parteien seht ihr sozusagen aufgrund des Wahlprogramms oder meinetwegen auch aufgrund eurer Erfahrung in der Lage da sozusagen was zu reißen. Also für die nächste Legislaturperiode wichtiges digitalpolitisches Thema. Welche Partei wird es erfüllen?
Seid ihr bereit? Nein.
Ist das eine Aussage über die Qualität der Wahlprogramme oder der Digitalpolitik in Gesamtdeutschland?
Pfff, nee, ist es mir so eine Aussage dazu, dass ich egal was hinterher rauskomme, ich will den zusammenarbeiten muss. Nein, also, nein, da bin ich natürlich in der schwierigen Position, weil natürlich auch keine einheitliche...
Okay, dann mach das bei dir so. Wichtig ist das digitalpolitisches Thema für die nächste Legislaturperiode. Das wichtigste Thema digitalpolitisch für die nächste Legislaturperiode.
Das wichtigste Thema. Also, wenn ich es gesamtgesellschaftlich sehe, es ist tatsächlich für mich so ein bisschen sowas wie Plattformkontrolle, Medienkontrolle halte ich für extrem wichtig, dass wir das gesellschaftlich in den Griff kriegen. Und ich hoffe, dass wir da auch ein vernünftiges Konzept für bekommen, egal wer jetzt rankommt. Also, infrastrukturtäglich müsste ich natürlich sagen, Data Center und Energie und überhaupt. Aber ich also rein gesellschaftlich und das ist glaube ich hier der entscheidende Punkt, dann sind wir aber bei dem was.
Weil Konz eh das letzte Wort haben wird, Aline. Wichtige digitalpolitische Aufgabe, die du siehst und wer kann sie deiner Meinung nach vielleicht erfüllen?
Naja, also ich beschäftige mich auch eben viel mit dem Thema Marktmacht und der der Digitalkonzerne, die durch KI einfach nochmal richtig auf die Spitze getrieben wird und wo ich dann halt mit großem Umbehagen so etwas sehe wie bei der Union. Und ja bei der Linken, bei den Grünen so zarte, also bei den Grünen zarte Ansätze, bei den Linken bisschen klarer formulierte Möglichkeiten sehe oder einen Willen sehe dagegen vorzugehen. Ja, ich glaube, auch wenn es dafür auch Europa braucht, ist das glaube ich ein Thema, was man in Deutschland prinzipiell gut setzen sollte und weiter treiben sollte statt es zurück zu drehen.
Zweiter Teil der Antwort. Welche Partei siehst du am ehesten in der Lage da was zu reißen?
Naja, also ich meine die Linke fehlt im Moment halt die politische Unterstützung.
Das ist schwierig. Also ich glaube sozusagen soll ich taktisch wählen oder soll ich wählen was was sozusagen am ehesten mir entspricht, ist eine Diskussion, die wir heute hier nicht führen können.
Ach damn, ich dachte wir hatten noch eine Stunde.
Nein, deswegen habe ich das falsch formuliert, wenn ich sage reißen können, weil das reißen können tatsächlich pragmatisch realpolitisch dann diese Frage hat, aber die Frage eher inhaltlich.
Also wie gesagt, zarte Ansätze bei den Grünen, eine deutliche Überzeugung klingt bei den Linken raus, die das überhaupt als Problem klar formulieren und verschiedene Ansätze diskutieren, wie man dagegen sinnvoll vorgehen kann.
Konz?
Hm, also ich schüme mich auch ein bisschen schön mit den, ich glaube, also die wichtigen Themen zu den vielen Zielen, so an denen ich so festmachen würde. Für mich wäre das denke ich schon auch Massenüberwachung, also wie stellen sich die Parteien dazu, aber muss ich dir ehrlicherweise sagen, dass natürlich bei manchen der Parteien, die wir heute besprochen haben, das so kurz ist, weil die ja noch kein vollständiges Wahlprogramm haben, dass das fast keine Erwähnung findet. Insofern würde das vielleicht, wenn Ende Januar komplette Wahlprogramme dazukommen, vielleicht auch noch mal ausreferenziert, weiß ich nicht. Also ich könnte glaube ich mit Sicherheit sagen, dass ich den Massenüberwachungsansatz der Union also absolut verfährt und rückwärts gewandt finde in so einer digitalen Welt. Aber ich muss andererseits auch sagen, neben KI oder Plattformen, was ich auch wichtige Themen finde oder auch IT-Sicherheit, was in der Stadt findet, glaube ich, dass diese Wahl für mich natürlich nicht unbedingt an digitalen Themen entschieden wird. Und deshalb tue ich mich natürlich schwer, weil die Aussagen, die jetzt so teilweise von den Kandidaten getroffen werden, die finde ich so jenseits, dass ich von den Kandidaten manche einfach nicht wählen könnte, selbst wenn sie coole Ideen hätten in Digitalien. Ich tue mich da so ein bisschen schwer mit mich auf einen eher.
Dann lass mich so sagen, die Frage für dich umformulierend.
Ja bitte.
Welche Partei hält sie für wählbar? Und dann zusätzlich noch der Aufgabe gewachsen, den Überwachungsstaat zu verhindern?
Also ich denke von den Ampelparteien fällt für mich durch die Bejahung von Massenüberwachung die Sozialdemokratie aus. Findet einen Paradigmenwechsel, den ich abstoßend finde. Aber da würde ich wahrscheinlich am ehesten auf linke, grüne und liberale gehen, aber die Machtoptionen sind natürlich sehr unterschiedlich. Ansonsten.
Also Interessant, deshalb noch, du hältst die Liberalen für wählbar?
Ich glaube halt einfach nicht, dass sie in den Bundestag kommen und ich finde natürlich auch so eine, also ich blicke natürlich auch zurück auf das Aussteherampel und frage mich, ob ich so eine Leute, die ja auch mit einem Honika-Ergebnis an Christian Dünner festhalten wollen, nochmal wählen würde, selbst wenn sie gegen Massenüberwachung sind. Der, das ist ja ein Navatten. Also, also, ja. Also ich habe auch mal den sozialliberalen Flügel der Liberalen gemocht. Aber jetzt kommen wir in eine ganz andere Diskussion, die wir jetzt ja hier nicht führen wollen. Wir wollen vor allen Dingen eins tun, was ich am Ende sagen möchte. Geht dahin. Wer sich weigert, sein Kreuz zu machen, macht es an der falschen Stelle. Geht dahin. Wählt. Ja, wir haben die Landtagswahl, da geht es hier sehen, die sind gruselig. Ich möchte jeden auffordern. Geht dahin. Wählt. Meine Message. Musst du nicht teilen, Markus? Ich seh dir ja immer nicht die Gesichter hier.
Nee, ich seh nicht, ich, ich, ich, ist egal.
Na und redet mit Menschen um euch drum herum. Also mach, mach diese Themen, aber ich bin auch plus eins für. Geht es so sehr um digitales, also ich glaub Grundrechte und, und ja, solche Themen sind noch mal viel wichtiger.
Weil das ist glaube ich eigentlich der Punkt. Ich glaube, hier zeigt sich ein anderes Grundrechtsverständnis und das siehst du in anderen Themen, nicht nur im digitalen, ganz doll deutlich. Deswegen werden für mich eigentlich manche Parteien nicht wählbar. Und da brauchst du nicht mal die digitalen Themen nehmen. Das sind ja auch nur Ausformungen von Grundrechten. Insofern, ja, da bin ich so bei dir, ah Mann, Alina, da hast du wieder das tolle Schlusswort.
Genau, der Erdrutsche in die andere Richtung muss weg.
Um das noch mal ganz deutlich zu sagen, diese Sendung soll keine Wahlempfehlung für euch sein.
Natürlich.
Diese Sendung soll einerseits konstant so kurze Gelegenheit geben, mich immer wieder zu unterbrechen, so wie es im Bundestag Politiker vielleicht auch haben zu machen. Aber andererseits soll sich euch die Möglichkeit geben, diesen einen Aspekt, nämlich den digitalen im Wahlprogramm, nicht selber arbeiten zu müssen, sondern vielleicht einen kleinen Überblick zu bekommen. Aline Blankertz, Klaus Landefeld, Constanze Kurz, vielen lieben Dank, dass ihr da wart und hier wart. Und egal, egal, wenn der nächsten Wahlperiode an die Macht kommt, es gilt natürlich weiterhin, lasst euch nicht überwachen und zerschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups. Tschüss.
20 Sticker auf dem Laptop.